[Music]
if you see somebody drowning somebody
whoever it is you can't turn your back
on them you need to help them those
people need help
[Music]
I see children that four years old five
years old they're supposed to play and
be happy and you know enjoy their
childhood instead they are risking their
life on those boats because their
parents know they either gonna make it
to Europe and they're not gonna make it
at all
[Music]
we're definitely the first and only
organization to be using drones to
locate the migrant vessels and distress
which really give us an advantage over
the other ships out at sea
[Music]
until that we can eradicate death at sea
we will continue our mission and we will
continue working diligently to save
lives at sea human tragedy continues to
unfold in the Mediterranean Sea which
has become a mass graveyard for migrants
an estimated 900 people